[Applause]
i
i'm talking
[Applause]
listen listen you just messed with the
wrong guy chad
who's your favorite wu-tang clan member
you speak english
and this is a different kind of movie
for you right this is kids and kiss
animal animals i love animals i have two
cats two dogs but
this animal is different
pig
turtle
is it true that everyone just goes
jackie chan yeah
i really hate that you know
whatever i go you know in europe in
america especially the father children
look yeah
why nobody see robert de niro
that's robert de niro wow daxton
so before we went out we said natalie
said we're going to have you name your
favorite kardashian who do you like
kardashian
doesn't mean kardashian do you know the
kardashians it's even better i don't
know
is that english that's english i've
never heard them they're armenian but
yes they're english okay the kardashians
how many kung fu movies do i have to
watch to become a ninja master oh
that's because that's all it takes is
just watching keep watching jackie chan
watch 200 and you'll be coming up and
then call us and then we'll let you know
yeah first time i i met steven spielberg
how can you make that movie human
dinosaur jumping together so easy jackie
i just pushed the computer
then okay
jackie let me ask you how can you jump
from this building that building it's a
more easy rolling jump action cut
hospital
but what was the thing recently where i
think you've broken your finger
your finger was in a splint do you
remember this story and you're on a
plane
[Music]
embarrassed
rash
at the end a weapon the french flag you
know throw the stun guy the stun guy in
the 260 don't fall down but when i throw
the
the
the the the
french flag you know yes the french fan
boom he saw it i caught my finger
out but he fall down everybody's are you
okay nobody care about me
because he's the stun guy
and also the camera on him i just ah
myself
and it's a swollen you know and every
day i just
you know i have to fight every day i
just
do this through this
yes
no
two weeks later
it's becoming very natural whatever i
just i just do
when the movie finished we go back to
los angeles
i was i was in the
i was in the
in the bed you know i was lying down
playing on the plane yeah
i was lying down
with my blanket
you know what happened
i remember at nine
at night i i would scale up i would get
up just
i was in under
i was just
i really pain
and uh air hoses yeah at night very dark
mr chen you want something
do you want some do you want something
to drink oh then i just
no
something
then her i can't feel her eyes something
to eat
no
oh i'm sorry
then i said yeah then when she go away i
look at myself
covered i take my blanket away
i just look in the hole
hi excuse me
then i just put
can i have water
[Applause]
[Music]
and did you get to relax over the
holidays
holiday i'm a have a holiday i'm not
like chris tucker one film six years
business
in america they use a sugar glasses
your glasses made of sponge sugar you
don't get hurt right yeah i i use the
real one
then i roll over the guy take the hammer
you know
break the window the window pan
explosion then i just out then i'm
coming back big hole here
you cannot spill the water you spill the
water and hit you and we're just just
walking like this and
uh 1 000 punch
and 500 kick
i mean you're you're literally a triple
threat actor singer and punch you in the
face
[Music]
which hollywood chris is your favorite
chris pine chris pratt hemsworth evans
or chris tucker
i mean come on i got to say chris tucker
i love you come on sucker
what what's the most fun you had filming
the movies with him no fun
filming with him
terrible
every every scene every dialogue's
different
you know you know my english i have to
wait for okay boom boom boom that's
that's my my
something like uh where are you going
then i said okay that's my turn then
second tick
different dialogue
different that
none of one same
10 takes 10 dialogue different dialogue
wait you want to do romance you want to
do romantic movies
i think you'd be very good in a romantic
role i don't know you should be offered
that role to owner
what's that
like u2o
jackie why did you lump me in
with you i hear myself with you oh yeah
we both yeah no okay
yeah and
i think
i i want to be a drum to will type right
now you know how to bet y'all have a
plane
what's that airplane
yeah i know you were an airplane but
what would you say before that i didn't
get that
plan plan
airplane airplane yes
they understand
i now know how to take down a guy with a
knife and
the last thing i really teach you
is when you see the knife
first
then turn run help turn
and then i'll call jackie chan get your
jacket
yeah i'm actually uh really uh
incredible my skills are really uh
amazing
[Applause]
this interview is over
how did who got the call how did you get
the call that you they wanted you to be
in this movie uh will smith
yeah
a few years ago i was in japan
restaurant i was sitting in the the room
and somebody said where was outside i
said yeah then they'll go i said well hi
yeah
then how you get here yeah we we we had
to make a movie together i said yeah
yeah yeah you know hollywood i mean
hollywood everybody see me let's make a
movie together yeah yeah yeah and i just
killed then
one years later i just call my office no
jackie i want you to do the karate kid i
said okay
who's the teacher
i thought i'm the clown again
i already forget how old i am
i still think i'm the kid he said no
you're the teacher i said what oh